cute dreamy music ah lovely few things
on earth are as beautiful as grilling
and few things get grillers more riled
up than arguing about gas versus coal
charcoal enthusiasts claim their fuel
infuses meat with special flavors and
they're right about that but wrong about
how it actually happens I'm sorry to say
that charcoal itself doesn't affect
flavor now the great thing about coal is
that it burns hot real hot far hotter
than a gas grill that's because coal is
pretty much pure carbon that means lots
of energy to burn when the juices from
your steak hit the briquettes they
combust all those proteins and sugars
and oils turn into a plume and rise up
into the meat that's what gives coal
grilled food a unique flavor doesn't
have so much to do with the aroma of the
briquettes as it does the intense heat
so make sure you keep it lit because
when coal cools down it releases a
bitter smoke so happy grilling and keep
those drips dripping
you